problem that exists now is not Chinese
anti-westernism or Russian
anti-westernism or or middle eastern
anti-westernism it is Western
anti-westernism the problem is people in
the west who've been taught to think
horribly about the West so that our
history is only a history of repression
and slavery and colonialism our history
is uniquely bad not uniquely good and
here's here's the most important point
in a way we have evidence for the fact
that this is flat out wrong how do we
know because the football proves it the
UN published another study asking people
around the world fleeing not just
conflict but economic deprivation where
do you want to go what are your
destinations people do not flee to
Putin's Russia they do not flee to
communist China the number one
destination that people around the world
want to go to is United States of
America and Britain and Canada and
others follow shortly afterwards now
that says something